il ya du nouveau
mieux vaut qu'ils sachent pas
il peut entrer mademoiselle vous n'avez
pas le droit
il se passe quelque chose qui puisse
effectivement j'ai des pouvoirs vous
avez son petit coin juste qu'il va se
produire un événement énorme qui nous
affectera tous
qu'est ce qui se passe sur ce vol veut
nous cacher quelque chose est qu on
atterrira jamais à mexico que ce que
vous voulez dire
l'un des trains d'atterrissage ne
fonctionne pas ils veulent me liquider
me regardez pas comme si j'étais folle
vous pouvez nous dire ce que vous avez
senti exactement j'ai senti
qu'aujourd'hui j'allais perdre ma
virginité
non
maurice allais
pour affronter c'est faux je franchirai
veux quand tu te mets à la joue et
héroïne resserra tu me fais peur samedi
mes collègues et moi nous efforcerons de
vous rendre le voyage plus agréable
possible
il ne me demandez pas comment
un an